Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And together we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us today for our 13th episode!
For Ruffians that are maybe joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every
Every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
So FUWAMOCO, in case you didn't know.
That's right, it's FUWAMOCO.
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Ruffians!
Not the left paw.
Not the left, the right paw.
Please remember to tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
It's up at the top right corner there.
Let's all do our best to BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
BAU BAU.
Moco-chan.
It seems like there's been another.
Pero Sighting!
I guess he stands out a bit, right?
Maybe just a bit.
Ruffians, you do such a good job finding Pero.
Where is he this time?
Where is he in this room?
What?
Where?
Pero's stuck in this dog's tummy?
What's going on here?
Ruffians!
Wait, how did he get in there?
What are you doing, Pero?
Is this dog sick?
Pero, Pero?
Maybe sick.
Maybe sick?
I hope this dog's okay.
I hope this isn't another symptom of BAU BAU-byo.
What's up, Ruffians?
You're next!
We are next!
I don't like the feeling I get from this photo.
It's very unsettling.
Right?
Is the doggy going to rescue him?
Maybe?
What's gonna happen to the dog though?
Is this what happens in the back rooms?
Maybe it's related?
Transportation.
Ruffians, do you have any answers?
Maybe there's some doctors in the audience?
Doctors!
Can you explain?
I obviously don't understand.
I'm not seeing any good answers.
No.
Rebirth.
That's not an answer.
Pero is baby.
Like this dog.
Very rude, baby.
I don't think that's how it works, Ruffians.
I don't think so.
No.
Hoping for the best.
Yes!
I feel like this is our most unsettling and intense Pero Sighting yet.
What do you think?
I don't know.
Ruffians, please let us know if you have any more sightings, okay?
Or an explanation.
Or an explanation, yeah.
Remember to use the hashtag FWMCMORNING.
That was disturbing.
That was a disturbing way to start our morning.
Just a bit!
It's gone now!
Let's all think about it.
It's over.
Okay.
On to the Happy Puddin' FUWAMOCO Morning.
It's not the happy part.
What?
Not the happy part?
Ruffians.
This is FUWAMOCO Morning, always all happy part!
We have another... A misunderstanding, huh?
Yeah.
So!
I wanted to say, this misunderstanding was again.
Again.
During our chat with all of Abyss.
During the first day of the Splash Party Potsuwa.
I was really confused, you know?
Were you Ruffians?
Were you confused?
Do you know?
Do you know what it is?
Do you know what happened?
I'm not seeing it.
I'm not.
So... Then it's important we talk about it today.
Yeah, yeah!
Have to clear it, you know?
Yeah.
So Nuresai... She was talking about... What kind of... Of rice... That she likes.
And, you know... She seemed really hungry, so... She was hungry.
You know, I wanted to make her hungrier.
Yeah.
And... I was playing with her like, Open up!
I'm the mama bird!
Here comes the rice!
It's piping hot!
And... And... You know... Then... Then she started...
Morning.
B-morning!
And I was really confused.
Right.
That would be cool.
And you know, I even saw comments on videos of it saying things like, Mococo is doing this on purpose!
And that I'm going to become like, some of our senpai.
Yeah.
I saw a comment that Moco-chan's like, Matsuri-senpai tweeting.
She's gonna become Matsuri-senpai!
Ruffians!
That's kind of rude to Matsuri-senpai, right?
Matsuri-senpai is Matsuri-senpai.
And she does what she does wonderfully, you know?
Moco-chan, you can't become Matsuri-senpai.
I don't know if I want that.
Moco-chan, that's rude.
I'm Mococo, okay?
She's Mococo.
It both starts with an M, but it's totally different, okay?
You know...
All I know is that I was framed.
I was just trying to be Mama Bird for Nurses Baby Bird.
That was where you made the mistake.
If you look, if you look, you can see my expression.
I'm very confused.
I'm very hurt.
Okay.
Go watch!
You can see.
There's footage.
There's evidence of me being very confused.
You got hurt by her moans.
Moco-chan.
I was hurt.
Yeah.
Okay.
I was framed.
Understood.
Misunderstanding clear.
You get it now.
Good.
Yes!
Innocent!
Okay!
Yeah, we're innocent puppies.
Always are forever.
Got it.
Yeah.
Not really.
That's your problem.
It's clear now!
BAU BAU!
So that means only happy things now, right?
Yeah.
No more sad things.
No.
Now onto the happy part.
I actually have something else I need to talk about.
Something else?
Maybe it's not happy.
What?!
It's something really, really important, okay, Ruffians?
And it's a bit embarrassing.
A bit for me, but maybe more for someone else.
For someone else?
Nerissa!
You know, we uploaded our Holo Summer Shorts, right?
Yeah.
I have something important to share.
So... Holo Summer Shorts.
This person's not gonna be very happy.
What?
Fuwawa exposed me!
It's a picture of you, not me.
Fuwawa doesn't know, but I caught her.
What?
She keeps on watching my shorts over and over and over.
You know, I'll call for her, and then I hear the splashing sounds from my video.
And I keep on asking her why.
And she says, oh, I just want to watch it.
I just want to watch it, Mococo.
And then she has a silly expression, a silly smile on her face.
I just, I can't help it, Ruffians!
You know, it's really cute!
Ruffians, you feel the same way, right?
It's making you feel the same way.
You were watching lots and lots with a silly smile on your face, maybe, too.
Right?
Right!
You get it right!
It's cute!
It just can't be helped!
I don't know.
I feel like, you know, it's a must watch.
50 times kind of sweat.
One time, oh it's cute.
Two times, oh it's cute!
You think it's that good?
Three times, it's really cute!
It's cute.
It's my sister.
You know, especially when Moco-chan laughs and then splashes.
And then, you know, she kind of gets a bit more of a ram.
Moco-chan, spicy!
Spicy?
I'm never spicy.
Never spicy.
Ruffians!
Make sure, if you haven't checked it out yet, that you watch it, okay?
Maybe 1 time, 2 times, 3 times, 4 times, 50 times!
100 times!
500,000 times!
Yeah, make sure you watch FUWAMOCO too, okay?
FUWAMOCO-chan, you should be proud!
You should be proud!
Of what?
Of your splashing.
I did a good job splashing.
You did, you did.
You got us all thoroughly splashed.
The next thing we wanted to talk about today.
This!
This, this, this!
We've received a lot of questions from you Ruffians about our claws.
Our magic claws.
Very important.
They're magic claws.
Here's a bit more information about them.
You might have seen it.
Right, right!
So, aren't they pretty?
Aren't they cool?
Mine are very good too.
I bet you wish you could have some too.
Ruffians?
Yeah, Ruffians.
You can't though.
But, most importantly, they used...
They're most necessary, you know, as part of our job as Demon Guard Dogs.
But I feel like, at least, as far as protecting your smile goes, they don't really have that much of a use right now.
But, you know, that's a good thing!
Yeah, good thing, right?
No violence.
I think, you know, Ruffians, if you got a taste of them,
Ah, your smile might be gone for good.
A bit, a bit.
Yeah.
They might have a couple smiles.
They hurt.
They hurt, you know.
Yeah, you might have a couple smiles.
A couple smiles now, huh?
Huh?
But yeah, we don't really need them, you know.
When we're taking it easy and relaxing with you.
Yeah, but.
Yeah.
We can put them away, so.
If we want to.
They're always there.
Whenever we want them.
But we didn't always have them though.
You know, only after we got to a certain level in our Demon Dog Training, that we got them.
You know, it happened when we got our claws too.
Important part of Guard Dog Training, you know?
And the strength of our claws is directly linked to the gem on the end of the claws just here.
A gem, very important.
Yeah, you know, uh... But... It's a bit annoying because Pero... Pero still likes to complain that we need to work harder to be able to get our claws much stronger.
I think it's pretty good.
I don't think we're weak at all, you know?
I think the Ruffians would think that they're very, very sharp.
Yeah, they're strong.
They're strong for now.
We don't need them that much to be able to protect your smiles, so... Hopefully.
Yeah, unless something really scary comes along.
But that shouldn't happen, right?
That shouldn't happen, right?
Ruffians, you're not gonna make us use the legacy, right?
Yeah, I don't think you want that.
I don't think you will last.
So, make sure you praise!
Praise Moco-chan!
Moco-chan, is that a threat?
Right?
Yeah.
No, no Berserker BAU BAUbers.
Yeah, I wouldn't recommend them for back itching either.
No, no, no.
For those times, a twin is helpful.
Moco-chan's good at back itching.
This is regular.
Regular.
Regular quiz.
Yeah.
One!
Ah, well, we also, we thought it was important that we talk about this today.
But this might be a bit more important.
You know, we've mentioned it a bunch, but, but, we really like pon-de-rings.
In case you didn't know.
Ruffians, you remember what they are, right?
Right!
Right?
The pon-de-rings.
Yes, yes!
Pon-de-ring, yes!
Yeah, pon-de-ring.
It's a donut that's like super mochi-mochi like and chewy!
But honestly, it's much more than just that.
It doesn't compare.
Ruffies, do you like donuts?
Do you?
Because you don't have to like donuts.
To be honest, we're kind of mixed on them.
Donuts are like... I guess they're yummy, but... Because of that, we kind of feel like it's unfair to call pon-de-rings donuts.
It's better than that.
Pon-de-ring is a pon-de-ring!
They're in their own class.
They're like bulls.
That's good, but pon-de-rings are better.
They're better.
I don't know!
They kind of look like a dog toilet.
They're really chewy!
You know?
The reason why it looks chewy is because it's CHEWY!
Yeah!
And it's really soft, too.
There's different flavors!
Like strawberry, or chocolate, or matcha sauce.
You don't have to have a chocolate one.
Yeah, no.
But our favorite is just plain.
You know, it's slightly sweet.
Yeah, you can't beat it.
It's just perfect.
Perfectly sweet.
Good balance.
But because of that, you know, I feel like you never really get tired because of it.
Exactly!
Perfectly sweet, so you could have something that's a bit more like bitter.
Yeah, good balance.
I wouldn't want to have soda with it.
That would be disgusting.
Unless you're maybe like a very strong sweetness Ruffian.
I think we're pretty strong, but I'm not that way.
Not that strong, no.
Because you know they're just perfectly sweet, you could eat a bunch of them!
A bunch of them!
I guess for better or worse.
Ruffians, can you guess what a normal order of pawings would be for us while we are both doing guard dog training?
Huh?
A hundred and one?
No.
That's a bit difficult.
A dozen?
Twenty each?
Ten!
It's a pool box.
A pool box!
They give you a special box, like a pon-de-ring box?
I don't know, it looks kind of like a... I think it's a normal donut box.
But if you only fill it up with pon-de-ring, then it's a pon-de-ring box.
It looks special, like you know that you're transporting them across the country.
Right!
Very official.
But we also make sure that we run a round of bites so they don't have a negative effect or anything.
Yeah, you know when you're doing training, it's okay.
But it's not like pon-de-rings would ever do anything horrible to you.
No, they only are good stuff.
They only bring smiles, you know?
It's like a special smile soup, right?
Right, when you look at them, they make you happy, they make you smile.
And then when you eat them, you take a... You get even a bigger smile!
Ah, yeah.
You know, they have a lot of the different, like, the pawns, the pawns.
How many pawns?
Eight pawns?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8!
I'm memorizing.
Eight pawns.
If it doesn't have eight, it's not right.
Yeah, it needs to be the eight.
Eight pawns.
Yeah.
So you can eat them slowly.
And share!
Right, that too.
Because you know, you can divide eight by two.
I can too, but we don't do that.
But it's possible.
If you need it to be there, you can.
And you can share it equally because you know there's eight.
There's eight.
Yeah, and then the other good thing about Pon-de-rings is that there's a king!
A king of Pon-de-rings.
He's very cute.
I want to know actually, Ruffians, do you know his name?
The king.
I think we talked about him too earlier.
Maybe that was during our Japanese Latsudance too?
Maybe.
Pondelion!
He's the king!
He's the king of the Pon-de-rings, the Pondelion.
You know there's a bunch of mascots, but he's the best.
Pondelion's the best.
What were the other ones?
Honeycooler.
Honeywooler!
I can't remember the other one.
But you know, I feel like it would be nice if we could be like the twin demon dogs upon the rings.
You know he's the king, we're the twin demon dogs.
I feel like we work well together, you know?
We bring smiles, we protect them, right?
It's a perfect balance!
So Ruffians, if you see Ponda Rings around, please have at least one.
Yeah, think about us, okay?
When you eat them, right?
But remember, you can tell a true Ponda Ring by how many of the ponds it has.
Eight.
Important.
Okay?
BAU BAU!
Ponda BAU!
Ponda BAU.
This is so good.
I can taste it right now.
It's good.
Almost as delicious as cats.
And next!
FUWAMOCO Morning Jingle!
Ruffians!
As you might know, we're looking for a jingle from you for FUWAMOCO Morning.
We wanted to say again thank you for so many wonderful submissions.
We've been listening to a bunch of them.
They're all so so so unique.
But we can only decide on one jingle, so... I think we'd like to showcase a bunch of them too, you know?
They're all so great, so I feel really mixed.
Yeah.
Does that sound fun, Ruffians?
Showcase?
Showcase some of them too!
Is that good?
Yes!
Okay!
Good, good, good, good.
But we also wanted to mention for creators, again, we're planning to use the jingle at the very beginning of each episode.
So, you know, once we transition to the studio and we play just right before we go, holo holo BAU BAU!
You know?
Just right there.
Yeah.
And also a reminder, the third line is quickly approaching.
It's on September 3rd.
So don't forget, okay?
Be careful.
It's almost September.
Almost.
Let's all bring close to August together and make September the best month we can.
Ever!
The best month ever.
Well, I think it's time for our Regular Corner's Doggie of the Day!
BAU BAU BAU!
Who's the Doggie of the Day today, Moco-chan?
We'll see.
De-den!
It's Coco!
Not Mococo.
Coco!
I'm not Doggie of the Day.
You're not Doggie of the Day.
You're never Doggie of the Day.
I'm always Doggie of the Day.
Huh?
No!
Coco is Doggie of the Day today.
Coco is very sleepy after being woken up early in the morning doing Splash Party Day 2.
I see.
Get a good rest, Coco!
Yeah!
Whatever, Mococo.
Well, I don't know.
Moco-chan, maybe you feel similar to Coco.
You sympathize a bit.
Yeah, I feel like this.
I feel like this right... Not right now.
Not right now, but recently.
Maybe on Splash Party Day too.
Maybe a bit.
Same expression.
It's good, you know, that this Ruffian snapped a photo of Coco's sleeping face and not Mococo's.
I don't think Moco-chan would be nearly as cute.
I would be a bit more angry looking.
That's for sure.
Maybe some drool.
Your tail would be all fuzzy.
You know?
Right?
Is that a problem?
That's a problem.
Ruffians don't want to see that.
What's that angry face for?
See, that's even better!
I told you so.
Coco's sleeping face is the cutest.
Not to be confused with Moco-chan.
How does Coco BAU BAU?
You know, like maybe a half asleep BAU BAU, or like sleeping BAU BAU.
Oh boy.
BAU BAU.
I just woke up.
You woke me up because of the splash party.
BAU BAU.
My English is BAU BAU!
A bit rough.
A bit rough, yeah.
Well, I think you know.
Coco, you know, even though you woke up Coco while having too much fun during the splash party, I think, you know, you don't really mind.
Go on a nice early walk together, you know?
She's just glad that you're having fun.
That's the most important thing.
But you know, there's probably the expectation that you're going to take her out bright and early for a walk though, you know?
That's your duty as her loyal and loving family, right?
Walks.
No leash!
Leash is probably a good idea, Moco-chan.
For you, no leash.
But for Coco, a leash probably sounds very good.
BAU BAU!
But today I went on a walk.
We have... De-den!
Such a nice walk on a foresty trail.
And together with your dad!
So nice.
Right?
Good memories.
Nice time spent together.
You know, we're glad you could spend that time together.
And, you know, I feel like maybe that might not say it, but with you, it made me really happy, too.
Yeah.
And you had your first Ice Pumpkin Spice Latte of the Year, too.
Special.
Extra special.
Do you like it better iced?
Ruffians, yum!
Because you can get it hot or cold.
I feel like it looks pretty cold in the photo.
But I guess if you're doing a forest trail, then it might get a bit hot, right?
The heart's pumping together with that.
Do you think we should try it?
The ice pumpkin spice latte?
Hot is better.
Ice.
Blended!
Like hot and cold together.
How does that work?
Hot!
Even in hot weather!
Extra, extra, extra birds.
And you saw some silly birds too.
I don't know how to pronounce those birds, but they sound pretty silly.
But I guess you know, before we know it, it's gonna be spooky season again.
No spooky.
Let's make sure to go on lots of walks before it gets kind of gross and weird out there.
Okay.
No wet dogs.
Not yet.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
And today for our Question of the Day!
What do we have?
Ta-da!
Does Mococo notice that she adds an A at the end of all her O and U ending words?
BAUI?
NOI?
YUI?
Do you do that?
When did this start?
How come Fuwawa doesn't do this if you're twins?
Hey!
Do I even do this?
I don't think I do.
Does Moco-chan do this?
I do not know this.
My BAU is totally normal, okay?
No, you're just trying to make me self-conscious of it, huh?
Right.
Just because we're not exactly the same on everything doesn't mean that we're less twins, you know?
You're not misunderstanding.
We don't have to go over this in the misunderstanding corner, do we?
That's a threat.
You know, I see comments being like, oi!
They are identical twins.
Just use your eyes, you know?
Fuwawa has bigger ears and different eye color.
They can't be identical.
What do you mean?
Are you calling our Maba Puppy a liar then?
On something so important?
Hai!
This is one of my favorite things I'm watching, you see.
Thank you!
I'm happy!
You're happy?
Good Ruffians.
So nice.
Yeah!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan, you do something like that, huh?
Huh?
Okay, well.
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan, you feel pretty, uh, fired up today?
Am I?
Maybe?
It seems like you are pretty, uh... Well, Ruffians, don't forget!
We're always looking for more submissions for Pero Sightings, for Doggie of the Day.
We want to hear more about your rocks and of course, questions!
Questions!
Ask me questions!
Rocks, not your rocks.
No, no pebbles.
Send your Pebbles to Biboo, okay?
That's the Biboo.
That's the hashtag Pebble.
We're hashtag FWMCMorning.
It's a bit different.
BAU BAU!
We'll be waiting for your submissions!
I've talked about a couple important things today, but I have something else.
Something really important I want to tell you, okay?
So, this.
This here is a Mococo pep talk, okay?
You're gonna hear it straight from me!
Now, you!
Ruffians!
You've made it to the middle of the week!
Congratulations!
Ruffians!
You're doing amazing.
You're doing it!
And you need to give yourself credit for that, okay?
You know, you woke up today to watch FUWAMOCO Morning and you know what?
After this, you're gonna make today amazing!
I know you can do it.
We all have days where we feel, you know, a bit off.
But we just need to remind ourselves to take things in stride and keep on at it, okay?
It's gonna be okay, because I believe in you.
You can do it!
I know you can!
Ganbatte-nya!
You awake now?
Huh?
That was amazing, Moco-chan!
BAU BAU!
Awake now!
You can do it, Ruffians!
You can do it!
Our next stream!
We have an Extra Special.
It's our one month celebration with you!
I can't believe it's already been a month since we debuted.
Ruffians, does it feel like that?
It doesn't feel like that.
Where did time go?
We blinked and now we're here.
It's here. 101.
But we actually have something very important that we'd like to share with you tonight.
We really hope you'll join us, okay? 101!
I know, you know, it's maybe a bit rough, maybe.
Ruffians are like, ah, it's rough.
Because we did so many celebrations recently.
I have to spend too much time with FUWAMOCO.
But you know, for us, one month really means a lot to us.
It does.
We really hope that you'll be there.
We're really excited to share what we have to share with you today!
And, you know, we're gonna talk about a bunch of our feelings, you know, from before we debuted, since then.
You know, we'll review some of our favorite moments from the past month and maybe talk about a future too!
We hope that we'll see you there!
BAU BAU!
And for what else is coming up, we have our schedule!
This upcoming weekend we're gonna be playing It Takes Two for the first time!
We did take a bit of a peek at it.
It seems like it's gonna be pretty chaotic.
I guess that makes sense.
If it takes two of us, it's sort of chaotic.
We can be pretty mischievous sometimes too.
I think Ruffians know that the best.
It's gonna be interesting.
On Sunday, we'll also be doing a very long super chat.
It started early so that it can end late.
It's gonna take however long it takes.
We're gonna get it done.
We're really really thankful and want to make sure that we can properly express our feelings to you and say thank you for all your support.
It means a lot to us.
It's been a long time.
You've been waiting a long time.
So, you know, let's have a lot of fun chit-chatting, being silly.
Oh well, you know, we're finally able to properly say thank you.
We hope you'll join us!
I'm not sure how long it's gonna be, but you know, one stream, the maximum is 12 hours.
We'll see!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Viewers today!
Aya!
BAU BAU!
The Lamb!
Onochi!
BAU BAU!
Close!
Jichu!
BAU BAU!
Name Doko!
Monji!
BAU BAU!
Kasuyuki!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!